sausage party left a ton of hurdles just
to get released who knew a cartoon about
a hot dog with a foul mouth and some bun
lust would spark so much controversy but
for all the reactions to the film the
weirdest stories happen behind the
scenes here are some details about
sausage party that even hardcore fans
may not know child-friendly sausage
party came about a dill slice away from
being burdened with an nc-17 rating in
the US but the ratings board is
apparently a bit more relaxed in Sweden
because they let the movie with this and
this hit theatres with an 11 rating
meaning kids aged 7 to 11 could go see
sausage party with an adult and kids
older than 11 could see it anytime they
wanted those parents must have been
thrilled happier ending the giant food
orgy at the end of sausage party came
out of nowhere
but it was originally even more filthy
than the final cut writer Seth Rogen and
Evan Goldberg gave the animators free
rein to be as creatively nasty as
possible and the result was 12 straight
minutes of food on food action Rogen
told indieWIRE we found out that
animators can be pretty sick when told
they can do whatever they want the
Naughty Dog movie studios loved a tie-in
deal but as Seth Rogen put it shockingly
no major sausage company wanted to
partner with a movie that condemns the
eating of sausages however the movie did
manage to work out a promotional tie-in
with the hot dog restaurant chain
doghouse
an in conjunction with the Sony Pictures
release sausage party dog house is proud
to present the Naughty Dog the Naughty
Dog consisted of a spicy kielbasa topped
with onions and horseradish mayonnaise
on a grilled bun which sounds delicious
but remember that hot dog only wants you
to love it
[Music]
casting call one of the first people
Rogan cast for sausage party was his
good friend oscar-nominated actor Edward
Norton you mostly know him from roles
where he doesn't play an animated bagel
I am Jack's smirking revenge
Norton loved the concept for sausage
party and even came up with the idea for
the character he'd eventually play
Sammy bagel jr. a bagel that sounded
like Woody Allen the only thing I've
ever pushed is my peaceful agenda which
banana I didn't push you know I I pretty
much passive-aggressively nudge Rogen
also thinks that Norton's early
involvement helped assemble the all-star
cast I think he was ultimately the one
who talked Kristen Wiig into doing it he
really helped wrangle the cast and
because he was one of the first people
involved in it it was easy to get other
people because we could always say we
got Edward Norton in the movie a
different direction
animated movies are time-consuming to
make so a lot of them have to credited
directors to split the workload this was
also true for sausage party which was
helmed by conrad vernon and greg tiernan
content-wise
sausage party was a huge shift for
Tiernan in particular although he's a
veteran animator who worked on projects
like all dogs go to heaven cool world
and the Tigger movie Tiernan's only
previous animation directing experience
was overseeing episodes of Thomas &
Friends that animated preschool series
about trains with faces it's not your
fault the weather stopped you doing your
job and isn't the important thing that
all the children's letters get to Santa
on time and then he did this
animator approved sausage party is
messed up in most ways you can imagine
nobody's gonna argue about that I was
afraid you left me because I wasn't
fresh anymore and then I was attacked by
a douche but people in the animation
industry seemed to love it after sausage
party hit it big at the box office
Sony mounted an Oscar campaign for the
movie and held a special screening to
drum up Academy interest in the movie
Seth Rogen gave a speech at the event
and afterward oscar-nominated animator
Bill Plympton came up to him and said
when you gave that speech before and
everyone applauded that was just great
that's exactly what we need people like
you to talk about thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our youtube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]